c'est la première fois que
l'administration américaine emploie le
terme le président américain joe biden
accuse lady mire poutine de commettre un
génocide contre les civils l'ukrainien
le budget de votre famille un plein
d'essence
rien de cela ne devrait dépendre d'un
dictateur qui déclare la guerre et
commet un génocide à l'autre bout du
monde les contours juridiques du
génocide ont été définies en 1948 par
une convention des nations unies le
terme désigne des crimes commis dans
l'intention de détruire totalement ou en
partie un groupe national ethnique
racial ou religieux
seuls quatre génocide ont été reconnus
par des instances internationales
dépendant de l'onu le génocide des
arméniens commis par l' empire ottoman à
partir de 1915 celui des juifs par les
nazis durant la seconde guerre mondiale
celui des tutsis au rwanda commis par le
pouvoir au tout en 1994 et celui des
civils bosniaques musulmans à srebrenica
en bosnie herzégovine en 1995 la
définition juridique du génocide suscite
débats et controverses notamment autour
de la question de son élargissement à
d'autres massacres car toute la
difficulté est de prouver l'intention de
détruire un groupe
le rôle de la cour pénale internationale
et d'éviter l'impunité le génocide le
crime contre l'humanité et le crime de
guerre sont des crimes pour lesquels
nous avons juridiction ces crimes sont
punis par la cour pénale internationale
actuellement des enquêtes sont en cours
sur les crimes présumés contre la
minorité musulmane rohingya en birmanie
et sur les crimes commis en ukraine